Have you ever wondered about the deepest desire
of SCP-2337, or Dr. Spanko?
Foundation researchers used SCP-978, The Desire
Camera, to snap a photo of Dr. Spanko while
he was eating a plate of gummy worms in the
center of his enclosure, and this was the
result:
"Inconclusive.
Dr. Naismith, who supervised the test, later
remarked the presence of a human face resembling
that of Welsh musician Tom Jones."
It should be noted that, before the photo
was able to fully develop, SCP-2337 grabbed
it, ripped it into pieces, and promptly ate
those pieces.
When asked to give an explanation, he stated:
"Apolojones of mine, friendola.
Profound embarrassassins, cack!
No what-newfangles of pussycats to be am thisward,
no joséways."